Olá você sabe quais são os sintomas de
um coágulo sanguíneo os sinais de que o
seu corpo possa ter um coágulo em alguma
veia ou pior ainda que um coágulo esteja
viajando e bloqueando uma artéria parece
assustador pensar nisso mas é
fundamental que você conheça os sinais e
sintomas aação de coágulos é uma das
principais causas de morte no mundo
justamente porque pode levar condições
graves como trombose venosa fundo em
bolinha pulmonar infarto e até derrame
cerebral é uma ameaça real e você
precisa Estar atento hoje eu vou
explicar de uma maneira clara e simples
como esses coágulos se formam quais são
os sintomas que podem indicar a presença
de um coágulo sanguíneo no seu corpo
tanto os sinais iniciais quanto os mais
avançados Esse é só o começo eu vou
trazer ainda mais conteúdo sobre como
prevenir identificar e tratar co agros
sanguíneos então
curta compartilha esse vídeo para que
mais pessoas possam ter acesso a essas
informações tão fundamentais tão
importantes
essenciais pessoal um coágulo sanguíneo
basicamente é como um curativo um tampão
que o nosso corpo forma para parar um
sangramento quando nos machucamos quando
tem alguma lesão então é um mecanismo
inteligente do nosso corpo mas isso pode
trazer consequências problemas se
acontecer de forma exagerada seja nas
veias ou artérias ou ainda de uma forma
recorrente repetida então vou fazer uma
analogia simples para vocês entenderem
Imagine que as suas veias e artérias são
como canos de água que levam sangue para
todo o corpo esses canos são muito
importantes e precisam estar livre sem
arranhões sem amassados sem entupimentos
ou danos então eles preciso estar Livres
Para que o sangue possa fluir de forma
adequada agora agora pensem que esses
canos podem com tempo sofrer pequenos
arranhões pequenos danos ou amassados e
quando isso acontece o corpo age como um
encanador competente ele envia um
curativo ao tampão que é o coágulo
sanguíneo para reparar Onde está
danificado e impedir que aquela veia ou
aquela artéria possa romper possa ficar
danificada ou até que ela vaze sangue
para outras partes que não deve ir então
isso é bom quando o dano é pequeno
porque ajuda a consertar o cano sem
maiores problemas consertando nossas
veias e artérias sem grandes
complicações o problema maior ocorre
quando suas veas e artérias começam a
ficar danificadas com muita frequência
especialmente no mesmo local por vários
fatores que vamos discutir mais adiante
toda vez que o corpo detecta um pequeno
dano dentro das suas artérias ou veias
ele manda mais tampões para consertar
então esses tampões vão se acumulando e
se juntam a outras substâncias presentes
no sangue que podem acumular-se naquela
região de uma forma inadequada Então
esse acúmulo pode formar uma placa como
se fosse uma crosta de sujeira que vai
se formando dentro do cano com o tempo
isso cresce e se torna o que é
convencionalmente chamado de placa
aterosclerótica estreitando esse cano
dificultando a passagem do sangue agora
imagine que em cima dessa placa que se
forma o nosso corpo percebe que tem
alguma coisa errada ali ele manda um
último coágulo um último tampão querendo
consertar aquilo quando o coágulo
sanguíneo se forma sobre uma placa de
aterosclerose em uma veia que já está ou
até mesmo numa artéria que já está
estreitada ele pode obstruir o fluxo
sanguíneo e causar um ataque cardíaco se
for numa artéria importante né no
coração ou um derrame se for no cérebro
dependendo da localização então por
exemplo se o coágulo entupir um cano ou
seja uma artéria do coração o resultado
pode ser um ataque cardíaco então se ele
obstruir um cano no cérebro pode
acontecer um derrame Mas o problema não
é só esse não se limita apenas a
obstrução local o coagro também pode se
soltar parcial totalmente e ser levado
pela corrente sanguínea adiante Então se
esse coagro for viajar ele agora é
chamado de êmbolo ele vai viajar entupir
um cano menor em outra parte do corpo
que pode ser nos pulmões no cérebro ou
coração então ele pode causar sérios
danos levando uma embolia pulmonar se
for no pulmão um ataque cardíaco ou um
derrame portanto tanto a obstrução do
local onde o coágulo se forma quanto o
deslocamento desse coágulo para outras
áreas do corpo podem resultar em eventos
graves por isso é muito importante
pessoal você conhecer os primeiros
sinais e sintomas de um coágulo
sanguíneo para que você possa procurar
ajuda o quanto antes e evitar as
complicações que pode causar no entanto
os sintomas podem variar dependendo do
território do local onde esse coágulo
foi formado ou para onde ele viajou
Então vamos começar pelo sinais sintomas
da trombose venosa profunda que acontece
quando o coágulo se forma em uma veia da
perna ou de outro membro mas é mais
comum na perna então quando você está
enfrentando esse quadro os sintomas
iniciais os sinais mais comuns são dor e
sensibilidade na região afetada que
geralmente ocorre em uma perna ou em um
braço embora seja muito mais comum
afetar a perna portanto não são as duas
pernas geralmente é uma perna só ou um
braço só é um lado só Além disso você
pode sentir dor e sensibilidade ao toque
pode ocorrer também cra na região
afetada Especialmente na perna ao
movimentar ou dobrar essa câimbra
geralmente começa na panturrilha você
pode perceber um inchaço na perna ou no
local afetado que pode ser apenas na
região específica ou se estender pela
perna inteira ao tocar a área afetada
você pode sentir um calor e a região
pode estar mais quente devido à
inflamação local além disso a pele
daquela região pode apresentar uma
coloração mais avermelhada então quando
os sintomas estão mais avançados outros
sinais também podem aparecer como é o
caso de uma mudança de cor mais
acentuada na pele que pode não se
limitar apenas a vermelhidão mas também
pode incluir uma coloração azulada ou
pálida devido à falta de circulação
adequada naquela região então o inchaço
ou edema pode também se tornar mais
persistente mais visível e esse inchaço
pode se tornar ainda mais grave mais
Severo sem apresentar melhora com o
repouso Então existe outro sintomas
menos falados porque são mais raros como
febre baixa mais contínua que ocorre
devido à inflamação associado ao coágulo
algumas pessoas também podem apresentar
uma pele que descama no local afetado
então a pele sobre a região do coágulo
pode se tornar mais seca mais camosa e
até com coceira Esses são os sinais
sintomas relacionados a trombose venosa
profunda trombose venosa profunda agora
os sinais sintomas de uma embolia
pulmonar são bem diferentes você precisa
entender que a embolia pulmonar é um
bloqueio causado por um coágulo que
ocorre nas artérias pulmonares
geralmente como resultado de uma
trombose venosa profunda quando parte de
um coágulo se desprende e viaja para
essas artérias no pulmão Então os
sintomas podem ser semelhantes aos de um
ataque cardíaco mas o sinal mais comum é
falta de ar repentina você pode
experimentar uma falta de ar súbita uma
falta de ar grave que pode ocorrer mesmo
em repouso Além disso pode haver uma dor
no peito que Geralmente piora ao
respirar de forma profunda algumas
pessoas também sentem ansiedade suor
excessivo tem desmaios e em casos mais
graves podem ter tosse com sangue agora
quando um coágulo gera um ataque
cardíaco ou infarto do miocárdio ele
acontece nas artérias coronárias que
podem ser obstruídas por esse coágulo
Então quais são os sintomas do infarto
do miocárdio então eles são parecidos
com da embolia pulmonar que eu já
mencionei Mas você além de sentir uma
dor no peito pode haver uma sensação de
pressão um aperto no centro do peito que
muitas vezes irradia ou seja ele caminha
pro braço geralmente o braço esquerdo
pro ombro e pro braço essa dor também
pode se estender pra mandíbula ou até
para as costas Além disso você pode de
falta de ar que pode ocorrer tanto em
repouso quanto durante o esforço físico
Esses são os principais sintomas Mas
pode variar muito existem alguns
sintomas menos falados que são mais
raros por exemplo você pode sentir dor
abdominal dor nas costas náusea enjoo
que podem ser confundidos como
indigestão estomacal se essa indigestão
estiver relacionada a outros sintomas
como falta de arou dor no peito isso
pode indicar um ataque cardíaco Além
disso você pode sentir dor em áreas
incomuns como pescoço ombro ou mandíbula
a ansiedade aumentada e até uma sensação
de morte iminente também são sinais de
alerta algumas pessoas sentem um medo
intenso ou um desespero que em alguns
casos pode preceder ou seja anteceder os
sintomas de infarto agora quando um
coágulo gera um derrame isquêmico também
conhecido como AVC isquêmico Ele
bloqueia as artérias cerebrais causando
essa condição os sintomas mais comuns e
repentinos incluem uma fraqueza que
surge de repente em um lado do corpo
fica assim sem força afetando também o
rosto o braço ou a perna Você pode ter
dificuldade para falar ou entender o que
alguém está falando podendo apresentar
um discurso confuso uma fala arrastada
Além disso pode acontecer uma dor de
cabeça súbita e Severa uma dor que você
nunca sentiu antes que é muito forte
muito intensa e que pode estar
acompanhada de tontura existe alguns
sintomas mais raros que quase não são
falados com a perda de visão em um olho
que pode ser temporária ou permanente
também vertige que é um tipo de tontura
perda de equilíbrio sem uma explicação
Clara de repente você está andando e
sente essa falta de equilíbrio
acompanhado de fraqueza repentina de um
lado do corpo ou mesmo dificuldade para
falar então todos esses sinais podem ser
sintomas de um coágulo que está causando
um derrame isquêmico um entupimento de
alguma artéria importante do seu cérebro
avci isquêmico pessoal fiquem atentos
porque eu vou fazer outros vídeos sobre
essa questão de trombos e coágulos
porque isso é muito muito importante
aumentou muito isso nos últimos tempos a
incidência tá aumentando é algo que traz
um risco significativo pra saúde com
possibilidad de sequelas graves e até
risco de morte por isso é um assunto que
você precisa entender saber as causas as
consequências e os sintomas
principalmente Eu pretendo fazer um
vídeo falando sobre as principais causas
dos coágulos Suplementos que são
interessantes para evitar esses coágulos
especialmente se você ter fatores de
risco então deixa aqui nos comentários
do vídeo se você quer saber mais sobre
esse assunto tá é muito importante a sua
opinião se você tem interesse nesse tema
Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço e um beijo no seu coração
Você é fera